[Applause]  the greatest thing ever have to tell you  I've been wanting to come in - oh hi -  good to see you - that good to see you  nice and you find good watching it in a  sense forever you are so great fantastic  and I'm the big say I'm the biggest fan  cuz they know whatever said they're your  biggest fan yes they are liars it's been  what 17 years now 18 years 17 years old  my gosh it was so great and then you're  standing there and you're warning  everyone's crying in the end the  confetti he's coming down you know way  too much not only too much confetti but  you're crying and you still had to sing  and just there he's pretending that he  didn't care that he lost I've been the  same ever since you've reinvented  yourself a couple of times you know you  have your own talk job I will not stop  talking until you subscribe to my  youtube channel that's right and I could  talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep  still here not going anywhere I see you  don't walk away from this